let's let's have intelligent discussion
let's have intelligent discussion why
you so I don't understand why you number
one hostile and number two I'm saying
let's have intellectual discussion we
don't need actual but you contradict
yourself that's not can something come
from nothing I am a man of physics I'm a
man of science mean which means what
don't
believe before the video starts guys
don't forget to check out Majestic musk
and utter Majestic musk and utter isn't
like the utter you commonly get
everywhere they are very high grade and
super long-lasting and are absolutely
100% natural they do a large variety of
things including designer inspired
fragrances pheromone fragrances
authentic masks and ouds purchase from
eBay or Whatsapp now the link is in the
description box below my friend how you
doing yes one of is it what's your name
Marco Marco how you doing Marco good you
look like a good man you got you slick
you got you got got Swagger I try my
best you don't need to try that much
you're looking goody who you here with
by
yourself hello how you guys doing
hello he's talking to
me please no no I'm totally fine I'm
just letting you know that I'm not
holding him up if you guys are cold what
do you believe in God obviously I've got
a I've got have you guys got you Dr a
free Cofe free Cofe you believe in God
you guys believe in God no huh I do I'm
I'm the only one I'm the only one come
on you intelligent man you should
believe in God you intent believe is it
I can prove to you God exists in 2
minutes
go for it I don't
believe you 5 Seconds well 5 seconds is
too short cuz 5 seconds is over yes yeah
yeah I know you get me five seconds well
well well if you're really sure about
your position you we can argue about it
you don't need to act hostile about M if
you got if you're intelligent we can
have intelligent discussion we can have
intelligent discussion I can prove you
got exist easily I believe then you
approved so I philosophy what what
philosophy got to do with God philosophy
has everything like what
oh what okay come can something come
from nothing than you have a good night
yeah God can come from nothing no God's
always been there there you go let's
let's have intelligent discussion let's
have intelligent discussion why you so I
don't understand why you number one
hostile and number two I'm saying let's
have an intellectual discussion you
don't need actual but you contradict
yourself that's not can something come
from
nothing okay so did the universe begin
to
exist no so the universe did not begin
to exist I don't believe that time has
begin or an end okay what's your
evidence for that cuz infinite yes
infinite doesn't exist in the real world
why not because it doesn't space is
infinite no infinite doesn't exist in
the real world space is infinite do you
believe in matter yes okay energy can it
be created or destroyed no in a close in
a in a close in a in a close system okay
in a close system it canot be entropy
interal discussion no no that's fine I
just I a man of physics I'm a man of
science mean which means what me that I
don't believe Darwin believes in God so
you're call him [__] you're an
absolute ignoramus believed in God he
said in my most fluctuations of my faith
I never stopped believing in God you're
an you're an ignorant person man just
you're just very hostile I don't know
why I'm talking intellectually you're
hosle I don't look I'm not here to force
you I'm saying let's have an
intellectual discussion I didn't say I'm
going to put a gun to your head believe
being you believe I ask you questions
that you cannot even answer
$50 might not be a large amount in the
grand scheme of things especially for
and I ask you questions can energy be
created or destroyed can anybody created
or destroyed thank you cannot thank
thank you man educate yourself mate
don't be hostile have a civil discussion
you are ignorant and you couldn't deal
with argument simple as that just say
that thank you sorry about this is very
hostile
weirdo ignorant bro let's have an
intellectual
discussion absolutely ignorant bro let's
have an intellectual discussion no I
don't care about God brother let's have
an intellectual discussion bring your
arguments I should be active like him
religious we're Blind Faith we belief
brother let's have an intellectual
discussion let's talk about energy let's
talk about God he's talking to me about
he's talking to me about philosophy he's
talking about science brother Darwin
believed in
God as you can see guys